- Look how it hits the thing.
Eww.
It's like, here (bleep)!
(laughing)
- Oh... please don't do that.
(funk music)
- Huge!
- Yah!
- Huge fan of Subway.
- It's like a good cheap go to,
that's not super, super unhealthy.
- Love me the five dollar footlong.
- I love bread!
I'm like Oprah!
- I like that jalapeno cheddar bread.
- There's something about
that special bread smell
when you walk into a Subway,
and you smell that fresh bread.
- Subway gives you so many options.
- Really good.
- Mm hmm.
It tastes like pizza.
- It tastes just like pizza.
- I like it.
- It's not bad.
- I do love those peppers though.
It's a little dry, the chicken.
- This bread is really good though.
It's almost better than a piece of pizza.
- Is it tired urban cheese?
- I don't know.
- Someone had a bunch of
random (bleep) in their fridge
and tried to make a sandwich.
And it's not good.
It just looks like a soggy (bleep) salad
and soggy (bleep) bread.
- Oh my god! I hate spicy food so much!
- Get her some milk!
- It's spicy, and it's
sweet, and it's soggy.
It's a triple threat of badness.
- Maybe just get the
sauce and the vegetables,
and leave the bread out.
- Make a salad?
- Yeah!
- Make it toastier!
- Why would you name a
sandwich 'The Heart Attack'?
- I have high cholesterol!
- (yells)
It's tuna and bacon!
- Oh my god. This is really (bleep) good.
- It's better than the others.
I don't even know if that's lettuce...
- Girl, don't look at it.
- Because you know what they say?
Never judge a book by its cover.
- This (bleep) looks bomb.
- It looks really good.
- I'm all about this.
- Okay!
- This is incredible.
- It's so good!
I can't stop eating it.
- This is definitely not bad.
- (Bleep) It's actually really good.
- It looks really good.
- This is not 'Subway, Eat Fresh' though.
This is Subway, Eat --
- Fat!
(laughs)
- I'm just not smart enough when I'm drunk
to make these amazing
combinations of foods.
- I think I'm just going
to stick to what I know,
when it comes to Subway.
I don't need to get all secretive.
- You know what's in it.
You don't need that soggy salad.
- The Supreme Pizza Sub was really good.
- That needs to be sold as a sub,
if they don't already have it.
- That's it. I'm done.